alvaro bedoya a name you probably
haven't heard is the guy's been
nominated by biden to serve on the
federal trade commission now we don't
talk about the ftc a lot there are a lot
of federal agencies out there this is a
pretty important one the ftc is the
responsibility of preventing or breaking
up monopolies and protecting consumers
privacy now because of those duties of
course it has investigated google in
recent years both of those are problems
google causes
and so far we believe it's been far too
lenient
so we're a little shocked to find out
that a former google lobbyist and
current google consultant is helping
shepherd badoya through the confirmation
process in the senate to get to the ftc
well that doesn't seem non-corrupt it
seems actually the definition of
corruption robert rabin is the man's
name he's a prominent democratic
lobbyist in washington his firm called
the raven group represents dozens of
clients raven himself was a registered
lobbyist for google as recently as two
years ago his firm still consults for
google the world's most powerful company
this show has been told by multiple
sources that raven is acting as a quote
sherpa for badoya and arranging meetings
between bedoya and various senate
offices again if that's true that's
corruption
we reached out to raben who confirmed
that his firm is assisting padoya
obviously a massive conflict of interest
here the guy who works for google
helping to install the guy
who regulates google
now you've heard a few democrats talk a
big game about breaking up big tech and
giving the power back to the public they
don't mean it
how do you know that
if badoy gets confirmed as an ftc
commissioner do you think he's going to
forget who helped him get the job
probably not and google is the company
that did the google that he's supposed
to be regulating
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else